Hilary Duff's home burglarized 80 can't  confirm the 29 year old actresses house  in Los Angeles was burglarized earlier  this week a rep for Hillary tells ET  quote this is a scary and upsetting  situation revealing Hillary her family  staff and pets are all safe the rep also  said she has a significant security team  in place that will work with the  authorities on this incident and handles  security measures moving forward  according to reports hundreds of  thousands worth of jewelry was stolen  from the home the younger star is  currently vacationing in Canada with her  five-year-old son Luca and has been  sharing the fun on social media posting  several pics and videos inner tubing and  lounging about during the Canadian  getaway  [Music]